ومن ناحيه الاخرى كده وزير الدفاع الروسيه
السير الجيش وان روسيا ستواصلوا تطوير ما
وصفه الثالوث النووي وستحافظ على جاهزيته
القتاليه كضامن لسياره وسلامه اراضيها
وشدد الشوق في اجتماعي بوزاره الدفاع على
ان روسيا تخطط ايضا لتوسيع الترسانه
اسلحتها الهجوميه الحديثه في المستقبل
القريب
والحفاظ على جاهزيته القتاليه لان الدرع
النووي كان ولا يزال الضامن الرئيسيه
لزياده دوله وسلامه اراضيها كما سنعمل على
زياده القدرات القتاليه لقواتنا الجويه
سواء فيما يتعلق بعمل المقاتلات والقادفات
في مناطق تشغيل انظمه الدفاع الجوي الحديث
او المسيرات نخطط ايضا لتوسيع ترسانه
الاسلحه الهجوميه الحديثه على المدى
القصيره كما سنعمل على تحسين العتاد
والمعدات التكتيكيه للافراد يجب علينا
اجراء التحليلات بشكل منتظم لخبره وعمل
قواتنا في اوكرانيا وسوريا وهذه الخبره
يجب ان تصبح اساسا لتحسين تدريب الكتابي
بقواتنا
وفي سياق المتصل لاعلانات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه قيامه طاقم الفرقاطه الروسيه ادمي
باجراء تدريبات العسكريه في بحر النرويج
واشاره الوزاره تحاكي عمليات تصدي هجوم
جوي لعدو محتمل في بحر النرويج في ظل ظروف
جويه صعبه
الاسرع من الصوت انطلقت في الخامس من
الشهر الجاري في مهمه العسكريه بعيده
المدى نحو المحيطين للعطلسي والهندي
والبحر الابيض المتوسط